So I am optimistically hoping that there
are going to be travel possibilities
coming up over the next six to nine months.
I do in theory have a wedding in Europe I'm
supposed to go to in September. So I sent in my
passport for renewal on January 5th this year,
and I sent it by regular postal mail. And
it wasn't even received by the passport
processing center for nearly three
weeks until the last week of January.
And the Postal Service has never been
more kneecapped than it is right now.
And a big part of the reason is Donald Trump's
choice for Postmaster General Lewis Dejoy,
who has been wreaking havoc at the
post office for the better part of
a year or longer at this point in time. Lewis
Dejoy insisted at a hearing yesterday that we'd
better get damn used to him because he plans to
stay in his position a long time. Take a look.
You're a political appointee, a holdover.
No one knows how much longer your board.
That's incorrect. I'm not a political
appointee. I was selected by a bipartisan
board of governors and I would really
appreciate if you would get that straight.
Well, how much longer are you planning
to stay? A long time. Get used to me.
Well, Joe Biden has a clear plan to removing
Lewis Dejoy, which would be really great for
the country. And anyone who either sends
or receives mail, which is most people
for everyone wondering why Lewis Dejoy is still
on the job and why Joe Biden hasn't simply
removed him and replaced him with someone else.
It's because the Postal Service Board of Governors
chooses the postmaster general. It's
not as simple as Joe Biden can just
replace Lewis Dejoy. So what Joe Biden and
Congress are going to need to do is to fix the
Postal Board of governors before they can have
him removed. The only other way I can think of
removing the postmaster general would be for
Joe Biden to make it a cabinet level position
so he can just pick a new postmaster general. That
seems like it would be relatively difficult to do.
So what Joe Biden is planning to do is he is
going to nominate three additional members
to the U.S. Postal Service Board of Governors. If
Joe Biden's nominees are confirmed by the Senate,
this would then give Democrats and Democratic
appointees the majority of that Postal Service
Board of governors. It's almost like he
is packing the court, except it's packing
the Postal Service Board of governors having
that majority. The Postal Service could then
vote to remove Lewis Dejoy from the position
of postmaster general. The three nominees
for Joe Biden are reportedly going to be run.
Stroman, who's a former deputy postmaster general,
Amber McReynolds, the CEO of Vote at Home,
which promotes voting by mail, and Anton Hajat,
who's the former general counsel for the American
Postal Workers Union. So the plan is very clear.
Nominate these three folks. They get approved by
the majority Democratic Senate. You get a majority
on the postal board of governors and then you get
rid of Lewis Dejoy. Now, whether it will happen
that smoothly remains to be seen. But this is
an emergency. As a reminder, the Postal Service
has been a target of the American right wing for
a long time. Remember that the way this fits in is
that the right wants the government doing nothing.
And as an independent agency under the executive
branch of the government, the right really wants
to get rid of the Postal Service. One thing
they've done is required that the Postal Service
prefund pensions of workers decades in advance,
which on paper makes the financial situation
of the Postal Service look much worse than
it actually is. No, for profit industry has to
prefund pensions that far in advance. It was a
calculated measure by the right to argue that the
Postal Service is financially insolvent. Another
way to hurt the post office is to make it work
so poorly that people stop using it, which then
makes it even less viable. And Lewis Dejoy has
done many things to make the Postal Service work
less efficiently, including eliminating overtime
pay for mail carriers so that undelivered mail at
the end of the normal workday, instead of getting
delivered, simply goes back to the post office and
gets delayed, sometimes for one day, sometimes for
many, many days. And as we've seen under Lewis,
the Joy On-Time Mail Delivery has declined from 96
percent to 80 percent. Some parts of the country
like Detroit, even lower, 74 percent on time mail
delivery. And this is sadly. A key part of the
Republican playbook, rail against the government
department or a government entity or a government,
an organization overseen by the government, then
put they get themselves put in charge of running
it. They make it run even worse. And then they
say, look, we told you guys, this is terrible.
We'll get you're making it terrible. And then
somehow they'll blame Democrats. And then when
Democrats come in and put together a plan to
fix what Republicans ruined, Republicans say,
who can afford that? That's really expensive.
This thing is functioning so terribly. We would
need so much money to fix it. We can't afford
that. Well, why is it running so terribly? It's
running so terribly because you destroyed it. So
it's a very common Republican playbook. And it is
one that unfortunately has worked well in many
areas. So we see the path. Three new postal
board of governors, members, Postal Service,
Board of governors, members, get them confirmed
by the Democratically controlled Senate. Vote to
remove Lewis Dejoy put someone in that position
who actually wants to improve the functioning
of the Postal Service rather than worsen it,
which is exactly what Lewis Dejoy wanted to
do, and it's exactly what he has done since